bonsoir olivier kohn merci d'être avec
nous la russie 1 qui reconnaît donc et
les efforts je cite un des talibans pour
stabiliser l'afghanistan vous
connaissent évidemment bien ce terrain
c'est qu'à stabiliser l'afghanistan ils
le font les talibans aujourd'hui alors
cessé alors déjà l'enjeu de ce sommet un
cake est colossal en réalité j'ai
presque envie de dire qui est encore
plus stratégique que le sommet qui a eu
lieu il ya quinze jours en italie le
sommet g20 où il était question
principalement de deux questions
humanitaires cette fois ci ce sommet
l'enjeu est énorme que vient chercher
les taliban les talibans ils viennent
chercher la reconnaissance
internationale tout simplement qu'ils
n'ont pas à l'heure actuelle les pays
qui étaient présents donc au sommet qui
sont essentiellement des pays de la
région dont des puissances régionales
cherchent à avoir un afghanistan
maintenant qui est stable et qui veulent
tout simplement que l'afghanistan ne
redevienne pas un sanctuaire pour le
terrorisme djihadiste international
c'est ça dont il s'agit c'est tout
l'enjeu de ce sommet donc je dirais pour
répondre à votre question concernant les
talibans est ce qu'ils vont pouvoir
stabiliser le pays j'ai envie de
répondre que c'est un petit peu
l'arroseur arrosé donc quelque part
parce que ces vingt dernières années
c'étaient les talibans qui était dans la
lutte armée l'insurrection qui posait
des bombes aux quatre coins
l'afghanistan quatre coins du pays
maintenant ils sont ils ont atteint leur
objectif qui était de prendre le pouvoir
et donc il se retrouve à devoir
contrôler le pays et est maintenant
c'est qu'ils font face à j'ai envie de
dire à pire que c'est à dire à la
branche locale la branche afghane de
l'état islamique
voilà qui s'appelle état islamique
heures la salle mais qui maintenant à
son tour posent des bombes aux quatre
coins du pays envoient des kamikazes se
faire sauter à kaboul et c'est ce que
faisait les talibans avant maintenant
les deux organisations sont sont reposés
son rival mais dans ce sens là
finalement l'état islamique avec des
objectifs qui sont une stratégie qui est
différente mais il remplace ils prennent
un petit peu le rôle qu'avait al qaïda à
l'époque en fait c'est à dire d'une
espèce de complot de jill djihad
international
donc ça veut dire si on vous suit bien
olivier crown que d'une certaine manière
il ya une forme de pragmatisme de ces
pays qui se réunissent aujourd'hui qui
salue certains efforts des talibans
parce que tout simplement il n'y a pas
le choix les etats unis sont partie
l'occident avec aujourd'hui il faut
traiter avec ceux qui tentent en tout
cas de tenir le pays contre des nouveaux
méchants si j'ose dire peut-être encore
plus méchant ou également méchant enfin
vous voulez vous le dire il n'y a pas le
choix c'est à dire il faut composer avec
ceux qui sont au pouvoir la barre etc
les talibans que nous avons combattu
pendant vingt ans avec le résultat qu'on
connaît tous maintenant ils sont au
pouvoir et eux mêmes n'ont pas intérêt à
ce que l'afghanistan le pays qui
contrôlent leur pays devienne un havre
de terrorisme international ou sombre
dans la guerre quoi guerre civile ouvert
internationale ceci dit c'est pas dans
leur intérêt donc maintenant leur
intérêt à eux c'est de contrôler le pays
donc à eux maintenant de faire le boulot
et les pays qui sont autour les pays
régionaux n'ont pas du tout envie de
voir se développer comme je disais
semblait des cellules de de l'état
islamique parce que l'état islamique est
composé de djihadistes internationaux
donc il ya des ouïgours il ya des
ouzbeks et des afghans bien évidemment
il ya des pakistanais enfin ça vient un
peu de tous les coins du monde quoi
beaucoup de la région
exactement c'est un peu la logique et la
crainte de toutes ces puissances
régionales donc tout le monde va se
prévu prémunir que ce soit l'ouzbékistan
les pays frontaliers vie d'avant
l'ouzbékistan le tadjikistan la chine
bien sûr parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
ouïgours volontaires ouïghours qui sont
qui viennent faire le djihad labassa
sais c'est pas quelque chose de récent
ce pas un phénomène nouveau et ça fait
depuis un moment mais toujours est il
qu'ils rejoignent typiquement des
organisations une organisation comme
l'état islamique rollason donc ça voilà
donc cessé mais il un la russie bien
entendu parce que son flanc sud les ex
républiques soviétiques donc sont
directement s'ils voulaient confrontés
au problème donc c'est dans l'intérêt je
dirais de tous les pays réunis autour du
sommet d'avoir un pays stable où il n'ya
pas de ne pas d'implantation saouler de
l'état islamique dont sont aliments
maintenant contrôler le pays en son
pouvoir de faire le boulot quoi en scène
plusieurs puissances se sont cassé les
dents en afghanistan
les occidentaux récemment les américains
il ya eu les soviétiques un peu plus tôt
est ce que les talibans sont en mesure
de tenir ce pays aujourd'hui est-ce
qu'ils en ont le pouvoir et les moyens
en tout cas c'est un pays qui
connaissent pour avoir été eux mêmes
dans la guérilla pendant 20 ans donc ils
connaissent tous les coins et tous les
cailloux du pays j'ai envie de dire ils
connaissent les méthodes parce que c'est
celle qu'ils ont pratiqué le même c'est
à dire vu à la fois de l'insuline de la
lutte armée de la guérilla de la guerre
irrégulière et puis du terrorisme les
talibans près pratiquer sa grande
échelle dans le pays maintenant ils
doivent ils sont confrontés à la même
logique
ils ont des armes et enfin c'est pas ça
qui est réellement ça apporte un plus à
des véhicules des armes etc ils ont
récupéré tout ce que tu as laissé
derrière l'armée afghane qui a déserté
maintenant si vous voulez c'est surtout
qui se sera probablement pas les mêmes
méthodes ils seront moins regardants sur
les droits de l'homme je dirais qu'ils
n'ont pas se mettre tout un tas de
contraintes pour arriver à l'objectif
ainsi ce soit sera beaucoup plus
répressif et ça sera pas dans le pas
dans le cadre des droits de l'homme ça
certainement ça se passera pas comme ça
et justement ces droits de l'homme ça
sera ma dernière question dont parle
beaucoup l'onu les nous les occidentaux
mais aussi quand même ces pays en ce
moment en russie c'est un combat perdu
d'avancé
pour le voir faire plier les talibans
sur ce point c'est évidemment que ce
sont des valeurs et des critères que
tout le monde avance pas seulement les
occidentaux la russie et la chine enfin
tous les pays il avance c'est important
l'inclusivité et je veux dire le
président poutine on a parlé enfin avoir
un gouvernement qui est inclusif
c'est-à-dire qui inclut pas seulement
des pachtouns n est elle pas seulement
des talibans et des pachtouns mais aussi
toute la diversité
ethniques du pays plus des femmes donc
c'est un critère que tout le monde
avance comme les droits et les droits de
l'homme bien sûr maintenant
si vous voulez c'est peut-être pas la
question qui revient qui vient au saut
en haut de la liste je dirais c'est
vraiment les questions sécuritaires qui
compte le plus accessoirement bien sûr
tout le monde veut que les droits de
l'homme soient respectés ce serait ça
serait un monde idéal quoi où les
taliban respecter les droits de l'homme
et ses quelque part aussi dans leur
intérêt en fin de compte parce que s'ils
cherchent cette reconnaissance
internationale et c'est ce qu'ils sont
venus chercher à moscou jean dont la
reconnaissance internationale bon un
moment donné il va bien falloir qu'il se
plie un certain nombre de règles à peu
près à plus ou moins commune quoi merci
beaucoup